so i watched the first few seasons of
suits what do you make of the whole
meghan markle
oh experiencing racism with the royal
family what was your experience with her
like
i'm gonna say this because this is some
one of those things that's really
really made me angry so this is what
i'll say megan
is one of the sweetest nicest most
intelligent thoughtful human beings that
i have ever met
in my life megan went out of her way
to always see how i was doing
to talk to me when we didn't have any
scenes together
but we might just be on set at the same
time she
is an amazing human being
and it bothers me so much
what's happening to her because
i know that what they're saying
is untrue
and so it's very very upsetting um
and just to be direct it's [ __ ]
it seems to me that there are people who
are setting her up
to be fall person there's people who are
setting her up to
to to blame her for something and listen
every single one of us as as human
beings
we've had bad days maybe we've sent like
not the best email
or you know who cares about that give me
a break
you know every single one of us has left
a message that that we might think oh
i was crabby that day or or you know i
mean every single one of us
so it just seems to me these people are
like really reaching
for any little thing that they can reach
for and
all i have to say is that she's one of
the most incredible human beings that
i've ever had the pleasure of
working with she's incredibly
smart and generous and
kind and lovely
and thoughtful i mean i can go on and on
and on so
i i wish her nothing but the best
and i just hope people over in britain
excuse my french uh leave her the [ __ ]
alone
i love that thank you so much for saying
that i think
all of her co-stars who have spoken out
have said the same exact
or have had the same experience with her
and it is unfortunate
and awful what's happened
to her so i'm glad that you could you
could share that that's nice when was
the last time you guys talked
i think the last time was the uh it was
one of the last times i was on set at
on seuss before she left i remember
we were it was in between takes and
we were about to move into like another
scene or something
and she was and she was sitting
talking to sarah in
gabriel's office or or you know um and
and and i came in and then sarah stepped
out and then and so megan and i were
talking while
they were setting up the next shot oh it
was uh
i just yeah i just can't say enough
enough nice yeah
did you know she was dating prince harry
before all this happened i did not know
at that time
she kept that like tight tight tight
tight
uh which i completely understand my god
but like
now i think back on that time i'm like
she was dating him then
you know so
but that's great you know like hilarious
yeah well hopefully i mean
things get better for her too because i
can't even imagine
listen like the thing about her is you
know she's strong
and she's resilient and if they think
that this kind of stuff
is gonna knock her off her game for very
long
they picked the wrong woman to mess with
she is the wrong woman to mess with they
need to back up
back off apologize cause
she's not the one she's not the one yeah
i love that uh db always a pleasure to
speak with you
you are wonderful i'm so excited that
you you're directing
do you know what you're gonna do after
lucifer yet are you gonna take a break
or
i'm gonna take a break and honestly um i
i think sometimes it's good for us
artists to like drop back and so i'm
gonna drop back there's something that
i've been working on um
as a writer for something uh for me
which i'm
you know putting it out there and and
hoping that i get a chance to direct the
pilot of this
new series uh for myself over on
amazon that's what i'm hoping amazon
you